c'est donc marine le pen avec ses
troupes qui sont arrivés à l'assemblée
nationale c'est historique regard des 89
députés et rennes vont siéger dans
l'hémicycle le patron des communistes
fabien roussel révèle que le président
lui aurait proposé d'intégrer un
gouvernement d'union nationale
quand on peut partir de rien puis
arrivée à l'assemblée nationale c'est à
dire partir de rien elle est femme de
ménage et finir députés à l'assemblée
nationale est un peu perdu beaucoup je
ne sais pas si l'union nationale est
quelque chose qui peut être mise à
l'ordre du jour tant il y a de défiance
envers le président de la république et
ses députés
j'entends que il a fait cette
proposition à un membre éminent de la
nuque très bien extrême gauche donc est
ce que il t'a fait la même proposition
il était clair il était nette le
président république ne m'a pas fait la
proposition de partie la conclusion que
nous en tirer mais c'est la finasserie
je considère que je n'ai pas à répondre
à une espèce d'injonction qui
consisterait à dire que parce que le
président de la république n'a pas la
majorité nous n'avons pas le choix nous
devons se rallier à lui et à son projet
politique n'a pas vocation à se
soumettre et dans la compromission et
être dans les petits comment dirais-je
l'accommodement de boutiquier de
monsieur macron nous ne sommes candidats
a aucun arrangement a aucune combine ou
à aucune participation à un gouvernement
avec le président de la république pour
la raison que notre diagnostic politique
et je lui ai dit il n'y a pas de
nécessité de gouvernement d'union
nationale il ya un parlement et c'est
pas ces cafés sont très sympathiques
évidemment mais c'est pas à l'elysée
qu'on doit faire la politique c'est dans
l'hémicycle pendant cinq ans monsieur
bakr ont essayé de nous effacer de la
carte politique et nous a méthodiquement
combattu en d'ailleurs provoquera des
ralliements qui n'ont servi à rien des
débauchages j'espère que c'est bien fini
au delà de notre groupe de nos groupes
de la majorité présidentielle sortante
ce qu'on appelle ensemble je rappelle
ccam 245 député c'est pas négligeable il
faut l'élargir par contre faire le
calcul par anticipation que grâce aux
voix du fn nous passerions un texte que
nous ne passerions pas sans eux c'est
non c'est une folie d'ailleurs c'est une
info ni d'ailleurs et les filles c'est
une faute ni l'extrême gauche mais très
droite nous sommes dans l'arc
républicain
c'est une erreur de vouloir effacer ces
deux grandes forces du centre droit la
nôtre et du centre gauche le parti
socialiste de la carte politique parce
que dans ce cas là quand les français
veulent changer ils n'ont plus qu'une
solution les extrêmes et c'est ce qui
vient de se passer si c'est pour
travailler avec un darmanin qui nie les
événements du stade de france qui nient
qu'ils apprennent de sécurité et
d'immigration à quoi bon avec un dupond
moretti qui ignore les victimes et adore
les racailles à quoi bon martin kallen
directeur général des événements de
l'uefa dénoncent devant le sénat les
chiffres avancés il ya trois semaines
par gérald darmanin c'est aujourd'hui
qu'on a eue au tour de 2006 ont oublié
qu'ils étaient faux les temps exige que
le premier ministre sous la première
ministre soit politique qu'on n'ait pas
le sentiment que c'est la technique qui
gouverne le pays mais au contraire les
sentiments profonds qui s'exprime dans
le peuple ce matin françois bayrou qui
sous-entendait qu'il fallait pas une
technicienne à matignon l'un politique
il y a un gouvernement reagan première
ministre est évidemment qu'elle est en
fonction et désirent dès ce matin d
après midi je peux dire que nous fait
travailler l'appareil touche violemment
le tarmac avant de prendre feu un
atterrissage digne d'un film catastrophe
alors que l'arrière de l'avion brûle les
membres de l'équipage évacuent les 126
passagers par le toboggan d'urgence
sandrine rousseau et dangereuse pourquoi
c'est une folie parce que parce qu'elle
dit n'importe quoi elle est hystérique
moi j'ai les reçus on l'a reçue elle est
à côté de moi et c'était la folie dans
ses propos dans tout son comportement d
un comportement attend c'est un accident
extrêmement rare qui serait due à une
défaillance du train d'atterrissage à
l'avant de l'avion c'est intéressant ce
que vous avez dit mais vous l'avez mal
dit elle me regarde de haut ou de
badauds comme elle peut
en fait plus petit que moi mais je veux
dire que rien comme ça veut dire mais
ils disent que je veux d'une agressivité
cette fille mais ça va pas un truc qui
va pas dans sa vie